[Music]
it is the story our 8 news now i-team
first reported last night that has a lot
of you talking a man originally charged
with 20 felonies under nevada's revenge
porn law agrees to a plea deal of a much
lesser charge and probation meantime the
woman who police say had intimate photos
and video shared hundreds of times says
she did not get any justice the i-team's
david charns here with the new case of
revenge porn that has a man sitting in a
jail right now david brian denise as you
mentioned we brought you that story here
at 11 last night that woman said she is
the one who was sentenced to a life of
shame while her ex-boyfriend who police
say shared hundreds of naked and
intimate images of her
walked away with probation
nevada's revenge porn law makes it a
crime to share an intimate image of
somebody else without their consent but
our investigation found police need the
victim to be identifiable in these
photos and as we showed you in the case
we profiled charges can be pleated down
to something much lower in this case a
charge of attempted unlawful
dissemination
he gets to go on probation in another
state and live his life and do whatever
he wants have you talked to him no nope
i've only had nightmares that i have
talked to him
now the law stipulated prison time in a
fine but it is up to prosecutors and
judges they have the final say now in an
unrelated case police say this man
43-year-old jason dixon uploaded an
intimate video to a pornographic website
right now he faces a charge under that
revenge porn law an indication police
are taking this seriously and charging
suspected offenders now in that latest
case the suspect is sitting in jail
right now without bail though he could
be on house arrest you can watch our
special report on revenge porn right now
on our website also inside our app i'm
david charns live local now